over the years black actors have brought
some of the most influential black
artists and civil rights icons to life
now we're taking a look back at just a
few of hollywood's greatest portrayals
of these
black history makers it is unacceptable
that they
use their power and keep us voiceless
the legacy of martin luther king jr and
his fight for equality
carries on in both history and pop
culture it really doesn't matter with me
now because i've been to the mountaintop
david or yellow took on the leading role
in the king biopic
selma which depicted king's 1965 voting
rights campaign
and the march from selma to montgomery
when
you as an actor are
[Music]
when you as an actor ah i'm so sorry
uh coming there as
as um someone who didn't experience it
they experienced it you're on that
bridge
it's it's no longer a film the actor
earned a golden globe nomination for his
performance
while the film earned an oscar
nomination for best picture
while chadwick boseman's role in black
panther will forever be his most iconic
the late actor's most acclaimed work
might just be in the james brown
biographical drama
get on up yes
the james brown prolific singer
songwriter often referred to as the
godfather of soul
chadwick had just starred in his jackie
robinson movie 42 when he landed the
role of james brown
just his second leading role in a
feature film it's a beautiful thing
get on up director tate taylor praised
chadwick for his performance in a
tribute
to the late actor published by variety
saying quote
he let himself go in his performance
without any sense that people were
watching him
it was unlike anything i'd ever seen
would you tell me what i can't do the
role of harriet tubman in harriet was
given to british actor cynthia arrivo
and not without contention from fans of
the historic idol
while many were excited for the news
some fans believe the role should have
gone to an african-american actor
the color purple broadway star addressed
the controversy in an instagram post
saying
in part my journey to this woman has
been long and detailed and one
i have not taken lightly i really just
want people to see this film and
know about her story the actress
performance did not disappoint earning
her her first
oscar nomination i was born yesterday
but i stayed up all night
denzel washington has enjoyed plenty of
success in hollywood
from films such as training day to
fences the on-screen legend has
never let an appearance go to waste but
it's roles such as malcolm x
the notable activists that have etched
the actor's name in the history books
you're not an american you're an african
who happens to be in america
malcolm x earned denzel he's third oscar
nomination
since we've been disconnected or cut off
from our own history our own past our
own culture
our own land we use the x the unknown
until we get back to our country